[Music]
hello boys and girls at your old pal Big
C they were coming at you with a quick
demo video sitting in a 2018 Dodge
Challenger with my boy Tyler here yeah
in Alberta star connector now on this
vehicle we were having issues pulling
the pin after we initially pulled it but
we have it I just erased keys you can
get a number of key zero on the system
of course it no worky hello future Larry
here editing this video totally
forgetting about the fact that we did
not show you that you need to access the
system by typing so go in by US Chrysler
drill to agree select by system
proximity faba car FH and we're looking
at type 11 okay back to it could add
smart key hazards are on as you can hear
so push the smart key next to the center
console pick the unlock button lock
cycle let it communicate programming
success number keys wine and work and
key